[Musik]
schweben im dreivierteltakt in dieser
tanzschule mitten in der hauptstadt
österreichs wird eine wiener tradition
an die nächste generation weitergegeben
der wiener walzer wurde im 18
jahrhundert zum mode tanz in wien und
wird noch heute auf bällen und partys in
der ganzen stadt getanzt
nun habe ich da haben wir ehrlich gesagt
ich wollte immer schon so tanzen können
wie all die prinzessin bei walt disney
und ich bin hier um das zu lernen
also bin ich der meinung ist es beide
entweder gleich leicht oder gleich
schwer je nachdem was für ein typ mann
ist ob man sich leicht mit der musik und
den schritten oder schwer
bei hoffentlich etwas wienerisches so
die wiener tradition
was machst du natürlich auch spaß und es
doch bände eigentlich am meisten gesamte
chelsea auch gleichzeitig ich finde ganz
harmonischen tanks er präsentiert
österreich und gehört zu unserer kultur
das netzwerk wenn sie irgendwo musik
spielen
es beginnt ja jeder sich sofort zu
bewegen und man kann einfach nicht
anders mit 60 takten pro minute gehört
der wiener walzer zu den schnellsten
tänzen der welt sein name wurde erstmals
ende des 17ten jahrhunderts erwähnt
damals etablierte sich der walzer als
gesellschaftstanz und wurde auch von den
bürgerlichen getanzt er begeistert bis
heute jung wie alt und das weltweit
dass der wiener walzer so beliebt ist
hat verschiedene gründe
ich würde mich lässt sich gut ganz
rechts mit links rum sage ich jetzt mal
ich finde die musik so schön
mit seinen kompositionen machte er den
wiener walzer zum internationalen
exportschlager johann strauß der musiker
und komponist schrieb klassiker wie an
der schönen blauen donau und er hat
überall in wien seine spuren
hinterlassen
in diesem museum ist sein werk und das
der gesamten strauß dynastie
dokumentiert helmut reichenauer hat das
museum mit begründet der pianist und
musikforscher hat viele jahre seines
lebens die geschichte der familie strauß
studiert die so viele große musiker
hervorgebracht hat
der durchbruch den verdanken wir schon
johann strauß vater um 1830 hat er
konzertreisen nach england und nach
frankreich unternommen und mit seinen
walzern größtes aufsehen erregt johann
strauß sohn hat dann diesen walzer noch
in der form perfektioniert auch dessen
bruder joseph war maßgeblich daran
beteiligt und bei den söhnen wurde der
walzer in seiner form noch vergrößert
in sieben räumen werden zahlreiche
originaldokumente gezeigt johann strauß
sohn wurde 1825 geboren und komponierte
fast 500 werke nicht weit vom museum
entfernt ist die wiener staatsoper die
jedes jahr schauplatz des wiener
opernballs ist er wird traditionell mit
einem wiener walzer eröffnungs besonders
viel getanzt wird natürlich der wiener
walzer auf den wiener wählen
bei diesen bald festen von denen wir
etwa 450 pro jahr haben also praktisch
jede woche außer juli und august finden
hierbei feste statt
da wird immer walzer getanzt vor allen
dingen schon bei der eröffnung gibt es
immer diesen eröffnungswalzer und damit
der gelingt heißt es üben üben üben wie
instanz schulen scheinen keine
nachwuchssorgen zu haben
[Musik]